Roland is with us in Joplin Missouri hi
Roland how are you doing are eight days
thank you so much for talking and thank
you for sharing common sense sure how
can I help
well I've been I've heard you speak into
people thoughts about loved ones and the
loved ones are making bad decisions but
I'm married to that person and some of
the bad decisions have kind of led us
and hurt our family medicine to a bad
place weren't homeless and very much
behind on bills yourself I like to get
all the bills caught up
what about 4200 ollars fine on just
regular bills of rent and electric and
utilities but yeah how is that her fault
partly mine too because I let it happen
yeah she long first off on the river a
truck driver and while I've been on the
road she loved her friends that she had
had troubles in their lives and become
homeless and she wanted to try and help
him so she let them move into health at
the time I didn't think he was a good
idea because we were kind of struggling
our health but um she went ahead and did
it anyway and a lot of our resources
have went into the last eight months for
trying to help those people try and get
jobs and get back on their feet and when
where are they now I've gotten all of
them out of the house there's only I
thought you had you were homeless
well we became homeless two weeks ago
before that how it happened we got over
of your foreclosed on no behind on the
rent and evicted okay all right so where
are you living
currently hotels campgrounds whatever we
can get into so obviously all of those
people you were helping are now gone
yeah
so what is your income right now about
40,000 mm-hmm okay and how far how much
do you owe in back rent about a thousand
dollars and how much D and you should
$4,200 and one else 1,700 and electric
500 in gas think we got the water caught
up and the rest is mostly recent medical
bills and that's another three thousand
or two thousand or one in about 2000
what kind of medical bills what kind of
medical event did you have Crohn's
disease sleep apnea and it's been trying
to get the sleep apnea taken care of and
doctors visit a lot of time for you I
thought I'm 34
how long have y'all been married will be
ten years of September alright so if I
were to sit down and talk to her would
she tell me she's learned her lesson yes
and I've also tried to sit down to hold
her and how kind of a dream meeting to
see what we can where we go from here
mm-hmm since she has learned a lesson
and what she tells me is that she
doesn't want to dream doesn't want to
think about it because she if we dream
that it doesn't come true because I want
to be disappointed well let's dream not
about not being homeless how's that that
would be awful that would be pretty cool
to not be disappointed you know and
let's dream about getting this little
handful of dirt you know five thousand
dollars changes your whole life what did
she do for a living
she's disabled they say to his kids this
takes care of the kids and how much
disability is coming in while she's
healing through the disability process
right now the courts what is the nature
of her disability it's physical pain she
had a head-on collision
and has left our injury unless out of
her body that prevent her from standing
for long times and or doing a lot of
physical work but she could do
white-collar work I think so because you
guys need some extra income right now
well so I think she needs to find a job
so that you're not homeless
and so the $5,000 comes in and you clean
this mess up so let me tell you what I'm
hearing rolling okay I'm hearing a
couple whose every individual part of
their life and their marriage is
completely spiraling out of control
there are so many different variables
that are crazy and what you gave me in
about a three minute thing here that
it's no wonder y'all ended up where you
are and I'm not saying that to put you
down I'm saying that there's a lot more
going on here than your wife couldn't
control her spending there's a marriage
breakdown there's her absolute lack of
judgment that's beyond belief and yet
she's supposed to be watching over
children and she's disabled and yet not
getting disability so she needs to be
working and you've got to somehow
interface with all of this and take over
these bills and put the family back on I
don't know that a dream meeting is in
order a crisis intervention might be in
order but I don't think a dream meeting
is in order we might have a nightmare
meeting like how do we get out of this
nightmare um but that start so what I
would tell you to do if you were my 34
year old little brother and you are is
to grab a local pastor and sit down with
them and let's start the process there
with marriage and spiritual walk and you
guys start trying to just push some of
the crazy out of your life and let's try
to get back to some solid ground in the
middle in the center of your life and
then rebuild your relationships based on
that and start making positive
responsible decisions both of you that
involve work ethic involved for gala tea
involved laying out a plan and you can
do every bit of that it's very very
possible but I I think that's where I
would start if I were you
as I pick up a phone call local pastor
say hey we're homeless
it's our fault we're not coming in for
money we're coming in for some
leadership and I as a young dad a young
husband I need some guidance pastor and
let that pastor counsel you as a man and
counsel you guys in your marriage and
let's lead you back into putting putting
together a solid plan and I'll put you
in Financial Peace University in the
area there but if that's all you do it's
not going to work because there's a lot
more going on here than just a financial
issue or to your financial problems are
the symptom of all the crazy going on in
your life and man you've got to sweep
the crazy out of the corners over there
that's what's that's what's overdue so
if you do that you'll see this turn
around but hold on Kelly will pick up
we'll get you signed up for Financial
Peace University and we'll try to figure
out what we can do from there so hey
thank you for the call we appreciate you
calling in hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]